Vice President Mike Pence is returning
from an unannounced trip to Afghanistan
pence met with American troops he said
the Trump administration is committed to
the war that the US has fought for 16
years now he gave the same message to
the Afghan government only on CBS the
vice president spoke with Margaret
Brennan at Bagram Air Base in
Afghanistan vice president Mike Pence
made an unannounced visit here to
Afghanistan landing overnight for key
meetings with its leaders and to visit
US troops there are now more than 14,000
us boots on the ground pence came to
talk to them reassure them but also we
spoke to him about the Trump legislative
agenda and that ongoing Russia probe the
president made it clear that we're going
to stay in this fight for our security
and to achieve a victory here in
Afghanistan but he asked me to develop a
relationship with President Ghani how
often do you speak with him it seems
like we speak at least once a month and
I met with President Ghani today heard
about the parliamentary elections that
that we're supporting and encouraging
next year he told me that they're moving
forward with their Election Commission
and the plans are on track for
parliamentary elections next year
presidential elections in 2019 heels of
this win on tax overhaul how do you
approach 2018 to see the Congress of the
United States come together passed the
largest tax cut in American history was
deeply inspiring to me do you see a
toehold to get more done you're gonna
see this administration move on
vigorously to an agenda which will
include infrastructure and welfare
reform one of the things that I know
frustrates the president and I'm sure it
must also stick with you is the degree
to which the Russia probe continues to
overhang all the things you just laid
out my view of all these matters is that
the special counsel has a job to do
we're fully cooperating when you say
you'll cooperate you mean you personally
are willing to cooperate with Bob Muller
you know we've been fully cooperating
with the special councils office and
we'll continue to just clarify how you
understand what happened with Mike Flynn
when he was fired did you know he had
lied to the other time what I can tell
you is I knew that he lied to me and and
I know the president made the right
decision with regard to him due to
security concerns Pence's visit was a
closely guarded secret with reporters in
a total media blackout until just before
his departure he is the highest ranking
US official to visit Afghanistan since
the Trump administration decided to
intensify its military engagement here
this summer for CBS this morning
Margaret Brennan Bagram thanks Margaret